sto veramente per fare questo video al
quale youtuber somigli quiz e test
nickelodeon a che calciatore assomigli
quale principessa disney 6 ma questi
quasi preferivo questo guarda quale
famosa youtuber italiana femmina non
questo modo fare delle attente ragazze
pervenuti a questo video sono fa vj
credo di essere favi già adesso vediamo
ragazzi allora iniziamo col primo quello
più conosciuto di tutti al quale
youtuber somigli che questo qua di poi
diventarono star del web come la mamma
di timmy scopo come la mamma di timi che
cazzo c'entra la mamma di trim che fa
youtuber la mamma di di rosa ma cos'è
greca menti da grande inizia non lo
sapevo scusa mamma di timi non lo sapevo
da ragazzi dai cominciamo anche sono
curioso di vedere come come va a finire
scegli una delle voci delle tartarughe
ninja
e questo che cazzo c'entra con l'essere
youtube
va bene facciamo questa quale passo di
danza preferì ma cosa c'entra con
l'essere youtuber pesoli facesse domande
su youtube tipo che tipo di video
faresti senologa minchia ariana grande
dai la prima perfetto quale cane al
travestimento migliore ma qual è il
punto discreto ma questo assolutamente
questo quale faccia buffa di ariana
grande ti diverte di piu questa e non
sto neanche dicendo a cosa mi fa pensare
in quale città vorresti vivere a londra
niente
minchia bella domanda los angeles quale
faccia buffa di genet ma che cazzo ne so
io chi è non lo so non lo so questa
quale spongebob vuoi mangiare ma che sto
mangiato la 5 minuti zio questo sembra
dolce va bene scottex come scott e sei
un artista ti piace disegnare
mi chiedo un freno non hai mai visto i
miei disegni zio da tua immaginazione
non ha limiti proprio come quella di
scottex grazie dovevamo arrivare alla
domanda 7 sera scotta insomma 10 va bene
d'accordo ragazzi passiamo al secondo
quello più strano ma quale famosa
youtuber italiana assomigli proviamo
la donna sono proprio contento di fare
questo quiz chi di loro sarà la tua
gemella youtuber scoprilo con il test
minchia non vedo l'ora iniziava raga non
sono sono cool brent e sei al centro
commerciale qual è il primo negozio in
cui entri accessorize cm guardi sicuro
non tezenis però facciamo se forse entro
dai cinema non lo so dai cinema o meglio
non lo so mi sono accorto di magliette
diciamo ai cinema per non mettere
mediaworld e va bene famoso youtuber ti
chiede di partecipare in uno dei suoi
video lui e michele bravi 36 zoda
richard hdtv richard cadetti da decide
di fare un video pubblicato su youtube
di cosa parli consigli per ragazzi
ragazzi comete ragazze depilate vi
l'ascella come il favi gen
tutorial di trucco chi preferisci tra
questi cantanti ma nel senso di bellezza
harry styles miley cyrus cristina tav e
ma tutta la vita chi ha messo cristina
d'avena e un genio scegli un tweet tra
questi legale avere fame a quest ora
posso comprare gli stivaletti
brillantinati sì io metterei proprio un
tweet così è solo per farvelo sapere
meglio le ascelle puzzolenti che le
banane ammuffite e per me non esiste
altro tweet all'infuori di questo velo
fatto vedere primo tra queste cose
proprio non sopporti insetti gli
invidiosi no invidiosi possono toccare
il proprio anno il filo delle cuffie che
si aggroviglia non ti sei perso neanche
una puntata di preti reader layers il
mondo di patty glee hannah montana
diario di una nerd superstar è il new
girl who che voi ci crediate o no c'è
una tra tutte queste della quale non mi
sono perso neanche un episodio ed è anna
monte ve lo giuro regalo guardava hannah
montana
la marcia in più e sorridi sempre ciao
non sai cosa sia la timidezza
esattamente questa te la cavi benissimo
le lingue straniere l'autonomia mettiamo
l'autonomia dotto principessa disney
preferita è il 6 fa per chi cazzo di
domanda facciamo ariel perché una rossa
gnocca [ __ ] il momento della verità sta
arrivando
siete pronti piacere non è che mi ha
trasmesso qualche gene strano durante il
video perché mai aiutato per marinella a
cazzo lo sapevo io non ci avevo fatto
caso a questa cosa e niente la
trasmissione di bit di cose greta che
cazzo mi hai fatto è quotato later
minchione che sta per scrivere che mi ha
trasmesso l'aids
va bene greta e non so cosa dirti io
fossi in te farei una maratona di hannah
montana poi non lo so attaccare da
ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo visto che ci
siamo ci sono un miliardo però vabbè
facciamo tipo questo ti piace guardare
video su youtube per dirti vecchie caso
lo fi sono cosa preferisce guardare su
youtube video game tipo di persona sei
sognatrice e romantica perché anche
questo mi ha passato greta con le sue
manine simpatica e socievole sicuramente
creativa e stilosa sicuramente sono
tutte quante zio facciamo loquace
ansiosa nel tempo libero ti piace fare
shopping ma ci mancherebbe altro che
alzi la mattina aprirà armadio e prendi
luci blu jeans non poter scrivere
italiano jeans e la maglietta 29 state
donate feat
la prima t shirt che capita conoscendomi
e cosa non sopporti degli youtubers il
narcisismo l'ipocrisia la cattiveria e
le bugie perché c'è qualcuno a cui piace
dall'ipocrisia non lo so il narcisismo
decide di fare un video pubblicato su
youtube di cosa parli in tutorial di
trucco che cosa minchia voi che metta
non vivi senza mi chiama un po di
fantasia ne vedo anche nell'altro testa
c'era questa sushi però l'ho già
facciamo smartphone ma se al centro
commerciale ma guardi prima amica entrò
nel negozio di videogame dai così a meno
s fa vj nomi usciti ma cosa ma corre ma
che cazzo di qui il sequestro
pepper shock spiega mia adesso adesso
voglio un commento qui sotto di pepper
ciò che mi devi scrivere perché sei
uscita tu se ho messo videogames
voglio capire sognatrice e romantica
queste sono le crei promesso loquace
stronzo cosa commesso sognatrice e
romantica queste sono le caratteristiche
che ti appartengono ti piace scoprire
posti nuovi assaggiare cibi diversi io
mangio pizza sei giorni su sette da
diversità ti distingue in modo
particolare da altri youtubers quante
quotato later che scrive più di pai la
monotonia non fa per te anche l'ombretto
e il lucidalabbra e il maschio palais
ragazzi spero che vito vi sia piaciuto
spero che tutti quanti vi ritroviate in
greta menchi e peppe chocolate 84 io
concludo gli episodi e cosa è piaciuto
un argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook è come dire a tenere iscrizioni
sono state sì di federici vediamo ad una
prossima puntata di hannah montana e o
un prossimo tutorial di make up visto
che tanto per ragazzi